paris ouest une zone industrielle et
commerciale de 130 hectares sur maurepas
et coignières 50 industrie 70
établissements de commerce et de loisirs
et plus de vingt restaurants et hôtels
en quarante ans d'existence parc a bien
changé
1973 création de la zone d'activités à
l'époque édouard jo par le père
fondateur de paris ouest souhaite
développer une zone exclusivement
industriel thyssenkrupp et achète seront
les premières entreprises à s'installer
mais les difficultés commencent pour
occuper les espaces vacants et qu'il y
avait une demande d'installation sur la
zone paris ouest il fallait l'accord de
l'état par le biais de la datar les
motards et évidemment on a cité les
entreprises qui souhaitaient s'installer
sur la zone paris ouest qu on allait
diriger vers saint quentin en yvelines
ce qui fait que c'était une concurrence
tout à fait déloyal parce que là c'est
zac c'était une société complètement
privée et qui n'avait pas de fonds de
l'état ce n'était pas une société
d'économie mixte étaient totalement
privées car paris ouest c'est un peu
l'histoire d'une bataille sans fin et le
premier conflit pour maurepas et
coignières avec la ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
foot d'industrie la zone se tourner vers
les activités commerciales le parc prend
officiellement le nom de paris ouest en
1986 leclerc s'installe un supermarché
de 15 mille mètres carrés au lieu des
trois mille prévus à l'époque la mairie
de coignières ne voit pas d'un bon oeil
cette concurrence pour les commerçants
de sa ville la guerre est lancée contre
le directeur du magasin
je suis habité race donc mais tda
publicité partout dans coignard sur la
route nationale surtout des actes et les
îles en inondé le paysage ce qui était
interdit par le publier de règlement
publicité sur première d'une part et
interdit également par la dde le long de
la route nationale 10 donc j'ai des gens
mon bon droit darche et tout ça j'ai été
comme un fort amusant c'est que c'est
mes employés municipaux qui collecter
toutes ces fléchettes qui les mettait
dans une benne et monsieur abihssira sa
laideur arraché et je dirais pour les
robes est de nouveau sur le terrain
aujourd'hui la paix est revenue aux
espaces industriel et commercial s'est
ajouté un espace loisirs dès 1996 trois
zones aujourd'hui bien délimitées nous
avons réussi d'une zone qui était aux
deux cinquième vide en 1990 avoir une
zone qui est plein à 95% pour les 5%
restants il faudra attendre de savoir si
oui ou non le projet d'installation d'un
cinéma multiplexe est validé